I am nine chanda from the
and we are delighted to have in our
studio back again Thomas Friedman
foreign affairs columnist of New York
Times and the author of the
just-published book and Tom is going to
talk to us about his book and also some
of the issues that argent issues with
yesterday tom welcome back great to be
here nine great to be here to talk about
that used to be us and in fairness I
should say this is co-written with a
Yale grad my friend Johns Hopkins
University Foreign Affairs professor
Michael manova yes so Tom the question
that comes to my mind is that you are
the foreign affairs columnist of New
York Times so what are you doing and I
think this book on America's domestic
crisis well it's actually even more
complicated I'm the foreign affairs
columnist of the New York Times my my
co-author is the chaired foreign policy
professor at Johns Hopkins what are two
foreign policy guys doing writing a book
about domestic American politics and the
answer is very simple we're old friends
um we're neighbors we've had a
conversation going for 20 years almost
daily about the world and we noticed
something in recent years we notice that
we start every day talking about the
world and end up talking about America
and we concluded really that was because
America its fate future vigor and
vitality was actually the biggest
foreign policy issue in the world
because we do believe America we we make
mistakes in the world we do some dumb
things but on balance we think we do a
lot more good things and that we are a
net provider of a huge amount of global
public goods whether it's keeping the
sea lanes open in Europe or promoting
free trade or you know spending money to
deal with AIDS in Africa we firmly
believe we are a net plus to the world
in fact we'd even go farther we are the
key provider of global public goods we
are in a sense the tent pole that holds
up the world and if that tent pole
buckles or phrase your kids won't just
grow up in a different America they will
grow up in a different world because
when America went into decline in the
sorry because when Britain
into decline in the 20th century America
was right there to pick up that global
stabilizing role if we go into decline
who is there to pick up that role yes so
I think this book is essentially you are
analyzing why America has gone into
decline yes and especially I am very
interested in this book specially coming
after your last bestseller the world is
flat because the world is flat and is
getting flatter yes the u.s. is now
facing the challenge that it is
self-created that globalization that was
this modern global issues created by the
United States and now it is feeling a
victim of the same globalization how did
it happen well no question you know we
face two challenges 91 is relative
decline that's inevitable and our friend
Fareed Zakaria wrote about that the rise
of the rest the rise of the rest was
inevitable with globalization and the
end of the Cold War what we want to
avoid is absolute decline where the
others aren't is rising but we are
meeting them and falling behind them I
think we're ways from that but that is a
real possibility and and that's really
what we we really try to explore in the
book we believe America made the biggest
mistake a country or species can make we
misread our environment we misread our
environment at the end of the Cold War
we thought the Cold War was a victory
and surely it was in every sense of the
term but it was also the onset of the
biggest challenge we'd ever faced we
just unleashed two billion people just
like us and then we provided the
technology at China and India China
India Brazil in Europe and eastern euro
all this pent-up emotion all his pent-up
energy and then we wired the world so
they could compete connect and
collaborate with us so much better and
so much more efficiently by the way this
is a huge net plus for the world I
believe but nonetheless it did provide
us with challenges that we really
weren't ready for because we won the war
so we put our feet up just when we
needed to be retiring our shoes then we
compounded it after nine eleven by
spending the next decade chasing the
losers from globalization called the
Taliban and al-qaeda rather than the
winner is called India and China so we
spent all this time think
about in planning about how to chase the
losers rather than thinking about and
planning how to really compete with it
when you put those two together and
explains a lot about why we are where we
are because the American deficit which
is no killing the u.s. is partly the
result of that war on terrorism exactly
it was a it was a huge diversion of
assets and huge diversion of attention
now we can debate in historians well
some of that was just an arrow we were
attacked it was not like these people
were innocent and and that it didn't
require some reaction the question is
did we overreact or did we overpay for
what we achieved and and we would
conclude sadly that we did that whatever
happens in Afghanistan and Iraq we
overpaid for it let's hope it is we
overpaid for something decent and
transformational in Iraq I think there's
still a chance for that in Afghanistan
I'm very dubious but whatever it is we
overpaid for now the u.s. invented
microchip the u.s. invented internet and
now these internet and microchip seems
to be posing a biggest threat to the
u.s. industrial hegemony oh well they do
and they don't of course we not only
invented the microchip and the internet
we invented social networking and all
the great social networking networking
sites facebook twitter linkedin and so
this is actually the next stage in the
revolution the problem with these new
industries 9 these these ministries
based on bits and bytes is they generate
enormous returns but very little
employment do you know that you could
take all the employees from Facebook
LinkedIn and Twitter and fit them into
madison square garden and still have
room for your family and then what
they're worth multiple hundred two
hundred billion I mean so they create
huge returns for their investors and
founders but they don't create a lot of
direct employment now at the same time
Facebook is creating opportunities for
people who want to become entrepreneurs
to become entrepreneurial globally to
share your ideas to collaborate with
others define markets and partners and
investors like never before so these are
enormously powerful tools and we are in
the middle of a whole new phase of the
IT revolution it's the combination of
social these social networking sites
mobile wireless enabled smartphones that
can get you right onto the web and then
is mobile social and what is the last
one it's the cloud so when your mobile
social in the cloud and suddenly in this
cloud you can actually get access to all
the computing power the clown Google
Health Lowry is the sound of our
capacity right that is made available
servers that store all these
applications but now u nyan can have
access to literally the same computing
power that Google has yeah you can rent
it by an hour do you realize what a
factory that puts up in the air for
anyone to access so the problem is when
we're in one of these transitions it's
very hard for people to see people can
only see the job they had or the job
they need and that's totally
understandable yeah but in fact a whole
new world is a parallel universe is
aborning they're the kind of jobs that
have been created exactly was never
known about exactly and we're just
seeing them and now we have four point
six billion people on the on cell phone
right that's a word where you realize
what that means that means then a decade
will have Universal connectivity that
you will be able to say that everyone on
the planet has a cell phone and when
that happens it's just going to be
mind-blowing because the cell phones are
creating lot of business model though
you in India you know as you know all
kinds of business models being done off
the cell phone now people will use it
for ill we know but think of the
problems we're going to be able to solve
I mean all of us are smarter than one of
us so imagine that all of us were able
to leverage to solve all that brainpower
that wasn't available is now going to be
available I find that tremendously
exciting yeah but the question of brain
power brings me back to the point that
you made in your book you said that that
Ching hai University and Beijing
University
are the biggest supplier of PhD to the
United States right now why is it
happening why is the US falling behind
in this area of well you know there's a
macro answer to your question and the
macro answer is that we had a formula
for success in this country we didn't
become the world's richest country by
accident we actually became the world's
richest country because we had don't let
anybody know I said this we had an
industrial policy there I said it we
didn't call it industrial policy but it
was a five-part formula for success
educate our people up to and beyond
whatever the technology is whether it's
the cotton gin or the supercomputer it's
a first-grade universal primary
education for an agricultural economy
then Universal secondary for a factory
based economy and finally the world's
best soap second post-secondary system
for a knowledge economy so that was our
first pillar of success second we had
the world's best infrastructure roads
airports telecom third we had the
world's most open immigration policy so
we attracted all the most energetic and
talented immigrants we call high IQ risk
takers to come to our shores and start
thirty percent to forty percent of the
new companies in Silicon Valley every
years we know and got two tons of Nobel
Prize exactly fourth we had the world's
best laws for incentivising risk-taking
and preventing recklessness and last we
had the most government funded research
to push out the boundaries of science
and technology and physics and math and
in biology so our venture capitalist
could pluck the best flowers and start
great new companies that both were
entrepreneurial and help people so that
was our five-part formula for success
well let's look at all five today
education by any global you know
comparison test a 15 year olds were in
the middle of the pack word around there
was Slovenia and Argentina um
infrastructure you know nine I just flew
from Hong Kong where we first met to LAX
los angeles airport that's like flying
from the Jetsons to the Flintstones
today ok really when you compare the
infrastructure a third immigration
policy where we have Republican debates
basically where the Republicans are
outbid each
on who can fry more people trying to who
can electrocute more people who are
trying to get into our country from
across the Mexican border now we are not
advocates of illegal immigration but our
mind should be really focused on how do
we get more people here illegally who
want to come here rules for capital
investing hodge like that subprime
crisis and lastly government-funded
research be it looks like that so if you
actually say well how do we get here and
what are we doing with how we got here
it's a terrible story we've taken our
formula and we put it all into decline
yeah I think your new book I have a very
interesting statistics you've said that
US consumer spent 7.1 billion dollar in
eating potato chips yes and the federal
government spends 5.1 billion dollar on
energy research just exactly yeah these
two numbers actually tell two stories
one is the obesity yes epidemic that is
hitting the United States and secondly
the price of oil and the habagat is
causing on the using idea no question
there's all kinds of weird anomalies
like that in California now spends more
in prisons and on education what we're
into we're into just a whole series of
bad choices what happens 9 is when a
when a country of society makes a lot of
bad choices over a long period of time
that's how a great country goes into the
client and we too much resemble today
the high school football coach who
always wants to tell you about that
touchdown he threw 30 years ago god I
was there and I threw that touchdown and
it was friday night you know Edmund but
I want to hear about the touchdowns were
throwing now and we're not throwing
enough and so this sense that America is
number one and still number one and in
deal life people are realizing that is
not the case so this dissonance between
the perception of America being number
one and the reality of the what we've
described so vivid linear book about the
shoddy infrastructure yes falling
education and falling health this is a
creating anger yes
in the public and that perhaps explains
some of the phenomenon like debarking
are right Occupy Wall Street that I have
seen the it's creating two things one is
anger or anxiety you know and you see it
in the Republican debates that it there
so aggressive it's against whether it's
against um gay and lesbian you know
couples or whether it's against illegal
immigrants there's there's a harshness
there's an exclusive pneus you know um
and what it is it it's um it's um its
scarcity thinking it's not abundance
thinking yeah I mean that's really what
it is its scarcity thinking and the
other thing is one problem and the other
problem though in fairness is that our
economy became so financialized so
dependent on Wall Street and Wall Street
you know turned out to be really off on
its own quasi-criminal jag where um it
got into the habit of what Jagdish
Bhagwati the Columbia economist calls
not financing creative destruction the
founding of new industries and the
replacing of old but really gotten habit
of financing destructive creation I mean
literally financial bets and instruments
using your savings in my ninth at work
had no more social utility than betting
on as they say in Guys and Dolls where
whether lindy sells more cheesecake than
strudel that's what a lot of these
people were doing in fact there was a
very important case that it was settled
last week that had Gaddafi not died I
think would have been really front-page
news and that was citibank agreed to pay
a fine of 280 million dollars to the SEC
now this is a very important case
because what citibank was was guilty of
although they admitted no guilt but they
paid the fine was actually going out
assembling a package of the most toxic
mortgages they could find selling them
to customers with one hand and then
shorting them with another now goldman
sachs did a similar thing but they did
it on behalf of a client who came and
said this is what i want to do citibank
did this for its own account okay
that's as low as you get and my savings
account is at Citibank so I take this
kind of personally yeah you did that
with my savings you know basically and
what's really scary night when you think
about I want to dwell on this but that
there was a meeting one day at Citibank
and somebody said I have an idea let's
assemble the biggest pile of toxic
mortgages about to default we can find
let's sell them to some of our best
clients and then on the other side of
the floor let's short them so we make
money coming and going and you know what
night this meeting happen and nobody
stood up and said excuse me that is both
illegal immoral unethical and completely
beneath our global brand nobody stood up
and said that this is a very basic story
yeah rekha this is this is piloting not
only the law the social contractor in
the country exactly and that's what Wall
Street's about yeah they're saying what
what is wrong with you people and here
you have to ask what is wrong with the
Republican Party because rather than
saying let's have a serious dodd-frank
financial reform they're basically
defending banks when I want to keep
regulation at a minimum I mean you know
a House Majority Leader Cantor called
them a mob the people on Wall Street
well if they're mob what would you call
those people at citibank there another
kind of mom okay gangster mob I mean
that's how they this is exactly the kind
of behavior you'd expect from the Mafia
um is it like a numbers racket yeah yes
so Tommy if we could switch to a bit to
these foreign affairs your your babies
yeah Obama president Obama has now
announced it complete pull out of your
second trip from Iraq how do you see
that this there's some people are saying
that this is pretty dangerous because it
was going to be exposing Iraq to the
possible yeah Iranian influence and all
the problems that would know what I say
nine I i I'm with President Obama in
this one because um by the way what part
of me very sick much sympathizes with
Iran
keys what their country back and they
want um they don't want American
stomping around their country and having
basically diplomatic immunity I'm not I
kind of get that you know I'm not kind
of because that was the condition on
which the talks failed that's why they
fail to do but I also i can understand
from their side you know we've we've
committed a lot good things a lot of
abuses as well and you know every rocky
has a story being caught in a traffic
jam or Americans over step in their
lines and whatnot and and yet we've
obviously done a lot of good things
there and invested as well but I
understand Iraq he's saying can we want
our country back and I'm not gonna go to
the Parliament and vote you know for to
give Americans immunity at the same time
nine Iraqis it's now 2003 were in 2011
heading for 2,000 shortly 2012 they need
to get their act together and that is
they need to sit down look each other in
the eye and say we're going to bury the
Shiites anything we're going to find a
way to live together and write a social
contract without always needing a
referee what why do they want us there
because they had when you strip it all
away it's because they don't trust their
ability to live alone together and at
the end of the day ladies and gentlemen
you're never going to get there until
excuse me we go and you get there and so
I think it is a risky thing I understand
why they want to be off the third wheel
but exactly it's taking off the training
wheels and time now to do that and where
because we became an escape valve for
them we became the valve that some could
blame and others could um your hide
behind now people say is a huge victory
for Iran I disagree I totally disagree
because i think for Iran they're not
going to have us as this lightning rod
that everyone in Iraq could focus on and
once we go who is the imperial power in
the region it's Iran and Iran in Iraq
fought an eight-year war now let's
remember that and that was not contrived
okay it wasn't just about Saddam I had a
thousand years of history that says to
me that arabs and persians don't play
well together and so i think this gets
very complicated for your own
now talking about Obama's decision on
Iraq basically you were telling me
earlier that Obama is basically ending
the foreign policy of Bush well right
can you elaborate on that well you know
it's ironic that that Obama is proven
himself very deft at finishing and
completing George Bush's war on
terrorism much better than Bush because
he's approached it in a very I think
smart tough way he's leveraged our
global intelligence assets and our
allies um used drones to engage in
targeted killings of known terrorist so
we could not get any other way bin Laden
there wasn't a drone that was a ground
attack but all lucky and in Yemen and
and Ben risk-averse yet ready to take
very calculated risk but generally not
getting us as in Libya overcommitted so
you can really say ironically Barack
Obama has finished George Bush's war
much better than george bush and the
country is better off for it at the st.
and i think this what drives republicans
nuts by the way you know okis who is
this neighborhood organizer used to hang
out with a bunch of SDS people and you
know and meanwhile he's doing it better
than the tough guys a score one for
obama but at the same time Obama has
been pretty much a failure in his own
foreign policy if you look at arab
israel conflict he completely made a
mess out of that the climate
negotiations completely made a mess out
of that Pakistan were not going to war
been in a war words with them
Afghanistan he doubled down in a way I
think was utterly reckless starting in
the transition um and so it's kind of
interesting in in his own foreign policy
he hasn't made much headway and I think
that has to do with the fact that what
is diplomacy at its heart it's making
deals between states signing treaties
resolving conflicts and I think the
reason we're much less successful
Obama's much less successful previous
administrations have been less
successful in fact there's been no
consequential secretary of state since
james baker and the end of the Cold War
because the world is so much messier all
these states that were propped up by the
Cold War are now rotting basically or
collapsing at Pakistan is a perfect
example and um and therefore there we
just deal with the military
and and at same time we're much weaker
we don't have the resources the leverage
diplomacy is all about leverage it's
just like negotiating your baseball
contract basically between you and some
owner you know who's got the leverage on
their side if we want have an effective
diplomacy visa V Ron we need to have an
energy policy that takes away their
leverage if we want have effective
diplomacy visa vie China we need a
savings policy and an education policy
and an investment policy that takes away
their leverage otherwise we're just
going around the world negotiating with
everyone without leverage well that's
your negotiating with China or Iran
without leverage that's like playing
baseball without a bat okay I mean you
know you really got no no way to deal
with the world and I think that's why
Obama is your targeted killing police
work we can do but deployment when
diplomacy is conventional like this it's
much it's much harder so I say to you
know mama don't let your kids grow up to
be secretaries of state but before that
time before finishing off is um you'll
say in your book that both Mike
mendelbaum me you are frustrated
optimists now why how can you be
optimist the situation that you
described well it's a good question you
know and and the reason the book is
called that used to be us that is it has
a backward-looking title but a
forward-looking theme is because um we
know we didn't get here by accident we
actually had this formulas for success
so if we could do it before why can't we
do it again we're not asking Americans
to become like India or China or Brazil
we has them to become like themselves
and that's why the book concludes by
saying the history books 9 we need to
read our our own the country we need to
rediscover is America that used to be us
and it can be again so so you are still
optimistic that America would come out
of this spin and not only my optimistic
now what's frustrating is that the
solution is like you could almost touch
it it's right here I mean if we had a
grand bargain right now we're basically
Republicans agreed to X amount of
short-term stimulus to get the economy
going again and Democrats agreed to
simpson-bowles plan for basically taking
nearly four trillion out of the budget
you know over the next
decade or so um we not only would have
the fiscal house in order to move
forward but we would um we didn't lock
the pessimism right now a lot of people
here I think in America feel like we're
all children of permanently divorcing
parents you know when you look at what's
going on at the national political level
it's actually very depressing do it's
not the kind of thing that really it
makes you say barred really to invest a
lot of money right now these people
really know where they're going so that
looks like the way that Republicans are
some determined to block any initiative
by President Obama yes might give me
credit exactly which means that this
situation will continue until the
elections well we're nots much worse
it'll continue after the election
because all the election will be about
is who can get 50.00 1% in order to take
power and then have no mandate for the
real changes we need my frustration of
President Obama is not that I could
totally understand the Republicans are
trying to splock him everything he does
my frustration is why are they getting
away with it man what women they're
mugging him in plain sight are they
getting away that may be because he
hasn't actually given the American
people reason to stand up and stop the
monkey mm-hmm maybe so easy to
communicate you think are they partly
failure to community partly a failure of
substance because any Obama's speech
beep yeah I finally travel a lot are the
Americans totally get where we are they
know we have a real problem and um they
know we need a real plan but the speech
that Obama has to give has to start up
by saying first and foremost Francis is
going to hurt and he's going to take a
long time we can either have a hard
decade or a bad century but it's going
to be one of the other and do here Obama
saying it dear people you know people
want us plan 9 in my view that's at the
scale of the problem they don't see that
for the president surgeon will see it
from the Republicans that is fair
everyone's going to contribute and that
is aspirational it has a big vision of
rebuilding and reviving America not just
balancing the budget because we have big
things that we can do to help the world
so I think one reason Obama's that the
Republicans have been able to mug him in
plain sight is that he hasn't
actually told people here is why I've
got them off mission here's I hear
something big that's my date well don't
thank you so much my pleasure and that
used to be us is now in the bookstore
sure is and dominating thank you very
much for visiting us great was a real
pleasure things like